[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
5 x 20 font 100
en 5 heures de vélo il est possible de
parcourir plus de 100 km
c'est parce qu'on stock mais venu l'idée
un peu folle de traverser l'Europe à
vélo de mon petit village de Saint jour
de Marennes dans le sud-ouest de la
France jusqu'à
Oslo en Norvège
alors bon un tel projet il faut le
construire quand même ça se fait pas
tout seul
ce projet ça commence par un soir où on
rentre du lycée et on tombe devant un
panneau portant l'inscription
scandiberric
après quelques recherches on s'aperçoit
qu'une piste cyclable
reliant
Saint-Jacques-de-Compostelle à la
Norvège passe juste devant chez soi
quelques jours plus tard vient un second
constat
qui vient faire germer cette graine de
projet
je roule à 20 km heure sur mon vélo
20 km par heure
en roulant 5 heures par jour
une journée correspond à une distance de
100 km
et en un mois
je pourrais arriver en Norvège
alors ça y est c'est décidé 5 fois 20
font 100
et j'irai en Norvège à vélo
alors forcément rien d'entrain j'en
parle à mes parents
qui me propose gentiment de commencer
par achever l'un de mes innombrables
projets avant de me lancer dans une tag
aventure
c'est vrai j'avais essayé d'apprendre à
jouer de la guitare basse après trois
leçons j'avais abandonné
j'avais également abandonné ma formation
de jeunes sapeurs-pompiers
mais pour la Norvège à vélo
c'était différent
alors j'en parle à des amis à des profs
avec la famille mais
il y a toujours ces sourcils français
et c'est doute
parce que c'est vrai que j'ai pas grand
chose en aventurier moi
parce que si je vous demande de vous
faire une image mentale de l'aventurier
vous avez tous très certainement une
image qui se ressemble les uns les
autres
pour les amateurs de cinéma c'est
Indiana Jones qui vient à l'esprit
pour d'autres ça va être Robinson Crusoé
qui par son génie arrive à survivre sur
un territoire totalement hostile sur son
île déserte
peut-être encore avez-vous en tête un
personnage plus historique comme
Magellan
qui part pour une grande première et la
découverte de certains détroits de
certains passages dans les océans au
péril de sa vie et qui donnera même le
nom un des détroits
oui c'est ça l'aventurier pour nous
ou encore peut-être que vous avez en
tête l'image de Mike Horn plus récent
cette aventurier sud-africain qui
partait pour le projet l'attitude 0
un tour du monde en suivant l'équateur
passant dans certains des lieux les plus
dangereux de notre planète
regarde ce que c'est que l'aventurier
pour nous c'est une personne qui prépare
minusciement
chacune de ces étapes
c'est une personne qui est préparée
physiquement également et qui a un
mental d'acier
et qui grâce à tout ça arrive à
traverser des territoires
au péril de sa vie
mais c'est vrai que moi j'ai rien de
tout ça quand je décide de partir
non quand j'ai décidé de partir
et la plus grande distance que j'avais
jamais effectué à vélo était de 70 km
je n'avais jamais bivouaké et d'ailleurs
tout le matériel qui me permet
maintenant de partir je ne le possédais
pas et pour certains outils je n'en
connaissais même pas l'existence
mais c'était pour moi une évidence il
fallait que je parte sur l'été de mes 18
ans
on m'avait vendu les deux années de
prépa ensuite comme étant un enfer il
fallait que je profite de cet été
alors c'était une évidence oui
une évidence jusqu'au 50e kilomètre à
peu près
et là on dit au revoir ces derniers amis
qui nous ont accompagnés
et puis on est seul
seul face à ses doutes
enfin seul oui mais pas vraiment
parce que quelques kilomètres plus tard
on se fait interpeller par un retraité
et tu vas où comme ça
en Norvège
ouais je vais en Norvège
et c'est là qu'on comprend
ça y est au 50e kilomètre on comprend
qu'on est enfin parti à l'aventure pour
de vrai
le matin du 7e jour
j'en suis à 692 km
ce matin-là il est un peu spécial
c'est le jour des résultats du bac
alors oui vaut mieux que je l'ai mon bac
parce que
sinon c'est
retour à la maison on prend le premier
train
et on va essayer d'avoir notre diplôme
rattrapage
c'est bon je l'ai eu
puissance une journée incroyable
ou on fait des détours on est dans les
Pays de la Loire donc on décide d'aller
voir Chenonceau Chambord
azay-le-rido on fait des détours pendant
toute la journée
et c'est une journée incroyable
jusqu'à arriver au camping
la nuit coûte 10 euros
et je n'en ai 9
j'essaie de faire valoir et indulgence
du gérant du camping
et j'ai le droit à une réponse qui m'a
vraiment réconforté
oui c'est comme ça mon garçon
dans les petits villages faut avoir du
liquide on prend pas la carte bleue
réponse bien réconfortante qui m'a
permis de repartir sur la route à 18h30
il est grave beau yeux dans les champs à
côté du château de Chambord
mais
[Musique]
cette nuit grave par hasard je trouve un
coin de chant qui pourra m'accueillir
alors j'y pose mes affaires je couche
mon vélo
et je ne déplie même pas ma tante non de
peur de me faire rejeter de cette abri
d'infortune
alors j'installe mon matelas
et je décide de dormir la belle étoile
cette nuage j'ai compris le sens de
l'aventure et le sens du terme dormir à
la belle étoile
tout juste le temps de se réveiller
de voir
un ciel magnifique
est un
on se rendort
mais on a compris ce que c'était
c'est donc ça qu'au
se réveille le lendemain matin aux
aurores pour une nouvelle journée de
vélo
peut-être que certains maintenant
auraient peur de partir
parce qu'effectivement on ne croise pas
toujours des gens qui sont très commode
ce gérant du camping en exemple mais en
réalité l'aventure
c'est des rencontres bien plus
importantes et bien plus marquantes que
celle-ci
le 11e jour je quitte Paris
depuis mon départ de Saint Geours de
Marennes mon objectif premier était rayé
à capital français
ces choses faites
maintenant le prochain objectif est bien
plus lointain me faut rallier Oslo
c'est pas encore la porte à côté
et cette journée tous les trains que je
croise
repartent vers le sud
direction la maison
alors on continue de pédagoger sans trop
savoir où l'on va sans même savoir où
l'on dormira le soir même
puis on arrive à Noyon à 130 km de Paris
et désespéré on commence à demander à
droite à gauche aux gens qu'on croise
dans la rue excusez-moi je suis à vélo
et enfin j'aurais juste besoin d'un
petit coin d'herbe d'un peu d'eau
potable enfin juste de l'eau déjà ça
serait bien
et je vous dérangerai pas
mais non
c'est un premier refus
on demande alors à une deuxième personne
puis une troisième
et enfin on trouve un compagnon
d'infortune
un chien vient jouer avec moi alors bon
s'amuse comme on peut dans ces moments
un peu difficiles
mais
vrai que ça maîtresse arrive
bon bah il faut essayer de lui demander
excusez-moi je prendrai vraiment pas de
place dans votre jardin et juste un peu
d'eau je vous promets
cette nuit là j'ai dormi dans un gîte
j'avais un vrai lit j'avais découvert
une vraie assiette pour manger
et José Roland cette femme qui m'a
hébergé chez elle
m'a offert tout un tas de fruits et
légumes venant de son jardin et m'a
surtout offert plus important que tout
une discussion sur l'écologie et
l'aventure
c'est ça les rencontres qui comptent
finalement
c'est ça les rencontres qui permettent
de reprendre ré-out après l'une des
pires journées de tout son voyage
et puis on repart
et on traverse frontière après
frontières
la frontière belge sous la pluie la
frontière allemande sous la pluie la
frontière danoise sous la pluie et un
vent horrible qui vous fait pédaler en
descente
puis la frontière suédoise
on commence à arriver dans le vif du
sujet et enfin
sous le soleil cette fois-ci on traverse
la frontière norvégienne
300042 km avant d'arriver à cette
frontière
mais ça y est c'est fait
le projet est fini
cette première aventure
tout ça ça fait
mais déjà on pense aux prochaines
aventures
on pense à essayer d'autres choses
peut-être à partir à vélo cette fois-ci
partir avec un sac
dans les montagnes
puis parfois ça se solde par un échec
on fait 7 jours de marche avant de se
rendre compte que c'est pas pour nous et
on arrête
mais on essaie
et puis on continue à penser sans cesse
à de nouvelles aventures
c'est pour ça qu'on me demande souvent
combien
ça sera quoi la prochaine
mais moi ma question pour vous ce soir
c'est vous
quand partez-vous
[Applaudissements]